so thank you first and foremost for
coming to the talk it's great to see
everybody here so as I just said my name
is Kyle Schaffer I'm going to be talking
a little bit about neural network so you
can think of this talk it's basically
sort of an intro to looking at neural
nets from an application standpoint and
in particular implementing through them
through a particular library namely
we're going to be working with the
Charis API for implementation here so so
let's talk about the main ideas that I
had behind this talk so what I want to
focus on here is sort of a couple things
giving some examples in some context
around common deep learning examples but
also sort of suggesting a different way
about learning these things and learning
deep learning in general more of a
practice centric way I guess as opposed
to a theory first way so many people
kind of come to deep learning and sort
of a standard way of learning these
things is right you go to some
foundational textbook that tend to be
fairly dense fairly technical and the
textbooks tend to use mathematics as
their main mode of communication right
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with that we certainly wouldn't able to
do deep learning without mathematics but
for beginners coming to the field that
can actually be a bit off pitting or
off-putting or a bit abstract right and
it's easy for people to kind of get
discouraged and think that well if I
have to go through this linear
progression of knowing the mathematics
and then proceeding all the way up until
I get to actually building applications
it can be a little bit of a discouraging
experience so so formal notation can be
a bit confusing an abstract for for
someone coming into the field and even
for somebody who's been been working in
it for a while so what I'd like to
suggest is that we can instead look at a
little bit of the fundamentals from a
high level just what our neural networks
in general how do they work how do they
represent data and then jump into some
implementation examples and that can
actually the lessons that we learned
from implementing these things can
actually inform our experience going
back to learn more about the
fundamentals so it's not that I want to
sort of abandon any of the fundamentals
or any of the mathematics I just want to
propose that getting into sort of an
implementation an early implementation
way of learning these things is not a
bad way to go and
we'll do that through a couple ways
because we're actually at a really great
point for learning this way recent deep
learning libraries have made prototyping
and implementing these things fairly
quick so we're actually there's a lot of
good tools for us to use we'll see that
as we introduce the Carius API so the
actual talk over to you these are the
things that we're going to cover we'll
do a very very brief overview of deep
learning in some applications we'll look
at the Charis library and introduction
to that which is the main tool that
we'll be using throughout this talk as
well as some other familiar scientific
Python tools like numpy we'll look at
implementing key examples of
implementing neural networks a
convolutional network for object
detection and then LS TM for document
classification and then we'll actually
look at once you built one of these
networks how can you sort of probe into
them to do useful things like
architecture debugging understanding
data flow through your network and maybe
even visualizing some of the weights in
your network and then we'll wrap up okay
so let's dive it in quick intro to deep
learning so we'll first start talking
about feed-forward networks because they
tend to be the prototypical example of
deep learning models and they're sort of
the the type of model that all of your
other flavors of deep learning models
are built upon so if they're a good
starting place so for the purposes of
this talk we can think about deep
learning as basically the application of
neural networks that have many layers to
machine learning problems right they're
applied to other problems in general but
for the purposes of this talk that's how
we're going to kind of think of these
things the idea is that the more layers
that we add to these networks the more
powerful our model becomes and the more
abstract features we can represent
through our data so this is a little bit
different way of thinking about machine
learning in general as opposed to the
traditional way of thinking about
machine learning of spending a lot of
time with writing code for future
engineering the idea is that if we have
a good Network for our tasks that
network should be able to learn a
representation on the fly that's
advantageous for a predictive task until
again we're talking about feed-forward
networks to start with because they tend
to be the prototypical example of deep
networks so I'm sure people have seen
diagrams similar to this this is just to
get up given over for you of what one of
these things looks like this is actually
a fairly shallow if you forward Network
but the idea is that we're looking at
basically an input layer here we're
feeding in our data in this case let's
say our data has four dimensions that
we're interested in feeding into the
network and then each of these layers is
going to pass data to some hidden layer
and in this case we're learning a hidden
layer that will have five dimensions
represented by these five neurons in
this layer and then after that we'll
pass this to a final output layer so
this might be a single node that's doing
binary classification a10 choice about
some data or might be a regression layer
that's outputting a real-valued number
or something like that so the main idea
is that these hidden layers each of
these subsequent layers takes as input a
previous layers output so we can think
of these hidden layers that sort of I'll
kind of talk about them in this in this
talk has sort of feature extractors or
data transformers and we'll look at sort
of some of the the transformations that
our data kind of undergoes when we look
at building one of these networks and so
the idea is that we pass data through
each one of these layers and then we
apply we apply a function which is a
nonlinear function called an activation
function to transform that data in some
way before passing it to another layer
so again the idea is that hopefully we
can learn the representation that's best
suited for our predicted task through
this architecture as opposed to doing
lots and lots of manual feature
engineering at the beginning ok so now
that we have an understanding of sort of
one of the basic building blocks of
neural networks we'll talk about a
couple different flavors as well so
people have probably heard of
convolutional networks as well these
tend to be fairly popular in image or
computer vision tasks so things like
detecting what type of object is in a
minute in an image segmenting an image
in two different sections like
foreground background things like that
or scene classification and the main
idea and the the the idea that these
networks sort of derived their name from
there's the idea of a convolution and in
this talk at a very very high level
we'll just think of a convolution is
basically a matrix or a sliding
that will filter over our image to to
aggregate features that are sort of
locally sensitive and again just as in
which just as in feed-forward networks
the idea is that deeper layers in this
network are able to learn more and more
general and abstract I feature
representations that are advantageous to
a predictive task so one nice thing
about convolutional networks is that
since they're often applied to images
they're very straightforward to sort of
visualize so in this case we're looking
at an architecture here right where
we're passing in some image we're
sliding a filter over it
we have convolutional filters that are
extracting features we have some layers
deeper in the network that are sort of
aggregating those features together
through a training process and then
finally at the end were outputting some
prediction and so at each step
what was this diagram has tried to
display is that in the early future
extraction layers right we're detecting
fairly low-level features things like
edges corners and things like that and
then by the time higher-level features
get get detected later in the network
the idea is that the network is able to
represent more abstract things like
object parts or maybe the nose of the
dog or things like that okay so you
might still be thinking what is a
convolution exactly this is a nice kind
of animation to understand what these
things are so again we can think of the
the convolutional filter is basically
this yellow matrix that's being slid
across this input image in this case
we're just doing an element-wise
multiplication from the matrix against
the each pixel value in the image and
then summing those up to have this
aggregated feature over on the right so
that's sort of a high-level view of at a
very high level how convolutional
networks work so finally we'll talk
about another flavor of neural network
will talk about recurrent Nets so just
just in the way that convolutional
networks are sort of tuned and has
special mechanisms that make them really
good for computer vision tasks recurrent
networks work the same way with
sequential data so the idea behind
recurrent networks is that instead of
considering each dimension in your data
set in isolation as an independent
sort of data point the idea is that
recurrent networks will try to learn the
dependency across those each individual
points within sequential data so this
makes them very popular for things like
natural language processing but also for
other things such as a time series
analysis or other sequence learning
tasks they've also been recently applied
to things like audio so for instance
generating music after being trained on
lots and lots of examples or generating
speech and things like that and so folks
- probably seen a similar diagram to
this so the main idea is that in a
similar way to our feed-forward Network
right at each time step we're feeding in
some data to our network I just like our
feed-forward network right we're passing
that into some data transformer that
then outputs in this case a hidden a
hidden representation of our data but
right the important difference here is
the lateral connections between these
cells here so each of these cells
labeled with an A is a recurrent cell in
our network and each subsequent cell has
information passed from a previous time
step to the current time step so this is
this is an example of sort of the guts
of an LST M cell long short-term memory
and so the idea here is that at each
time step in your data set an individual
cell is taking in this past state which
is represented by this top arrow here so
this is sort of like summarizing all the
past information that your network has
seen and then we're combining that with
data from the current time step through
these various transformations so in the
case of this cell at each time step your
network is sort of deciding what new
information do I combine what
information do I keep from the previous
time step and then what information can
I forget so the idea is that you don't
have to decide how back in your time
series to look the network should learn
that on its own if it's a well-formed
problem ok so we've talked at a high
level about two different kinds of
neural networks that we're going to
explore in this talk next we'll talk
briefly about an introduction to Kharis
which is the main tool that we're going
to use to implement these things so if
you haven't I'd encourage you to look at
that carrots homepage I'm sure a lot of
people have already there's some great
documentation
and examples there but the main idea and
the reason I've chosen it for this talk
is that there's some really nice
properties about the curious library as
far as existing being existing software
the main thing being that it abstracts a
lot of the implementation details so it
allows us to kind of think instead of
all of these different moving parts that
we need to worry about it kind of allows
us to think in a modular way about say
different types of layers that we'd like
to incorporate into our network then
thinking about how do we string those
things together to to have data flow
through our network so we can really
just think in terms of this sort of
sequential stacking layers workflow and
think in terms of model building instead
of getting bogged down in a lot of say
optimization code or something like that
so the general recipe that will kind of
look at for a lot of examples here is
outlined here so the first thing we'll
do is we'll use a pre-built class in
Kerris to basically build an empty
container and we'll see what that looks
like in a second and then we'll choose
the set of initial layers that will that
will be used as our feature extraction
layers and we'll push those to this
container will link those layers
together with activation functions that
apply some non-linearity and pass the
data to subsequent layers and then
finally we'll add some kind of output
layer for our actual prediction and that
might be an output layer for multi-class
prediction a binary prediction or even
regression we'll stick with the
classification cases in this talk so
kind of filling out the example here
right so Kerris has the sequential class
that we'll be seeing a lot in this in
this talk so we're instantiating an
empty model here that we're going to
push layers to just as we stated before
in this case we're just building a
simple feed-forward network so the first
thing that we're going to push is this
dense layer with the 100 units so we're
transforming our incoming data to be to
have a dimensionality of 100
within this layer then we're linking
this layer to another dense layer with
this activation function there's a
series of different functions that you
can choose from we won't worry too much
about that in this talk
then we'll add another layer and then
finally pass this to our final layer
which is just a single node in this case
so that's the main idea behind Karis and
we'll sort of understand a little bit
more as we go through additional
examples so let's do that now let's look
at a couple different examples for
actually implementing some neural nets
for for some specific tasks so the first
thing we look at is a convolutional net
for object detection this is basically
straight from the Charis example so if
you want the full source code definitely
look at the curious github that looked
at under the examples for for this
particular example so there's another
set of nice built-in aspect of the
Charis library and that they provide a
lot of prepackaged datasets so if you're
familiar with using tools like
scikit-learn this should look familiar
to you right scikit-learn comes with
things like the IRS data set for you to
use and play with in a very quick way
there's a couple of canned data sets
here as well so for the object detection
task we'll look at this initial data set
which is the sy part n data set so in
this case we have a data set of 50,000
fairly small images and the idea is that
we want to train a network to bin each
of those images into one of ten classes
so say a dog a cat a frog or something
like that so looking at some initial
code basically what we'll do is we'll
import a function or a class rather that
will load these load these datasets
pretty nicely into train and test splits
so we don't even have to worry about
that in this case we'll import another
function that we'll use to transform our
labels so often in again at you're
familiar with scikit-learn often you can
pass sort of just a one dimensional
array even in the multi-class case to an
estimator here we actually need to
transform that a bit and so our labels
are actually going to be a matrix as
well as our input data and so the shape
of that matrix as you can see at the
bottom from our training labels is just
going to be the number of rows being the
number of instances in our data set and
the number of columns being the number
of classes that we want to predict so we
have a one hot encoding of those labels
going in and so this if folks haven't
worked with sort of like
multi-dimensional arrays or tensors this
data format might look a little strange
so what
we're looking at here for the training
data is just 50,000 samples and each
sample is an image which is 32 pixels up
and down 32 pixels across and then as a
dimensionality of three at the end one
for each color channel are red red green
or blue and so it's nice is that we can
actually slice into that array just as
you would any other numpy array and look
at some of the incoming data so here I
think it looks like we're looking at a
frog my neural net the texture would
maybe not be so good at this test but
hopefully our net will be but it's just
it's just to show you that it's a very
similar it's a very similar sort of a
data type as a lot of other tools that
you're probably familiar with okay so
now we can actually get to building the
code for the network we'll start with
some input statements here a lot of
these should look pretty familiar the
ones that we'll focus on here since
we're building a convolutional network
will be this con 2d class which allows
us to quickly stack and build up
convolutional layers for future
extraction and this max pooling layer
which will do some of that aggregation
that we talked about in our initial
diagrams so let's look at how we
actually put this together so again
first off will instantiate we'll follow
the same recipe as before right will
instantiate sort of an empty model
container using this a sequential class
the first thing that we'll push is one
of these convolutional layers and so
there's a couple arguments that are
important to look at here the first
being the filters argument here so
remember what we talked about
convolutions at the beginning we sort of
saw that animation of this yellow matrix
sliding over an image and sort of
extracting features from it so this
argument is basically saying how many of
those filters do we want to slide across
our image to construct features and then
for each of those images we can choose
the dimensionality of that filter so in
this case we're just sliding a three by
three matrix over our image to aggregate
features and then feed those to
subsequent layers in the network it's a
little bit confusing for terminology
we're using kind of flipping back and
forth between filter and filter and
kernel you can think of those it's the
same thing in this case so just as
before we're linking that first
convolutional layer with an activation
function to another layer that we used
to extract features same idea here we're
using 32 features same dimensionality
for each filter size here and then
linking that to a max pooling layer
which again is going to basically
aggregate those features before feeding
them to subsequent layers in the network
and the next block we're basically doing
the same thing so we're adding more
layers to our network again the
intuition here being that the deeper
your network is the more abstract it's
going to be or the more abstract
representations that the data is going
to be able to represent literally the
only difference here is that we're
adding more filters at this stage and
this is you can think of this is kind of
like a hyper parameter that you can tune
throughout the throughout the model
building process yes yeah yeah
I would say honestly if it's your first
crack at parameter tuning it might not
even be things like filter size our
number of filters you could often times
the optimal see that you'll at the end
of sort of like building one of these
architectures you'll choose an
optimization algorithm to actually do
the learning part and often the choice
of that algorithm can have a big effect
on your learning tasks and there are
other things with that algorithm that
you can change as well so you can change
things like the learning rate so the
value of that learning rate can be
thought of as how aggressively do you
want the algorithm to try and learn the
function that you're forcing it to learn
but for things like this I mean really I
would I would focus on examples and then
if you sort of start at say swapping in
a different learning algorithm or
changing learning rate or something a
little bit more general then you can
sort of drill down into these layers and
look at these things but this is that's
a good question and this is just to kind
of say that like it's easy to think of
these things as a black box but you can
sort of go in and tinker with them but
you're right to point out that there's a
lot of moving pieces so that's kind of
what makes architecture building sort of
a little bit of still an art more than a
science okay yeah
yes Omar somewhere in the guts of the
curious code those those filter values
are being initialized we can so there
are there are a couple of arguments that
you can pass for basically that will
basically point to distributions that
you can sample from to initialize those
weights but in this case in this case
that that's just the default that's kind
of like hidden from us for now yeah good
questions okay so at this point we
basically have a network with input a
bunch of feature extraction layers and
that's it so what we need to do at this
stage and what's typically done is we'll
employ this flatten function which will
basically take the output of our last
feature aggregation layers and flatten
that out into a big long vector and
we'll feed that vector into another
dense layer in this case and again these
are sort of individual design choices
that you can make in building your
network and so at this stage you can
think of these dense layers as sort of
the start of a feed-forward network on
top of your convolutional filters so you
can you can kind of see how a lot of
these networks can sort of be wired
together in ways to suit your predictive
tasks and so here again we're client
we're applying a non-linearity to link
this layer to a final prediction layer
which has ten nodes one for each of our
classes that we want to predict and then
finally we're applying a non-linearity
for our final predictions which will
output a probability distribution over
those classes and which using the
learning algorithm here which I talked
about a little bit before and some
metrics that we'd like to see during
training and here right once you finally
built your model this should look very
very familiar to folks who are familiar
with scikit-learn right we have a fit
method and we're calling it on our input
data our labels the only difference here
being that we have an epoch sarg youment
which basically states how many times do
you want the network to pass over the
training data in order to do its
learning okay so that's it for actually
building the network so as it's all
machine learning algorithms right we can
rely on
different performance metrics that are
probably familiar to people things like
accuracy or precision to sort of have a
high level understanding of how our
networks doing but sometimes we can we
may need to look at more nuanced options
for say debugging and network or things
like that so in this case what we'll do
is we'll actually visualize how
confident a model is in predicting for
an individual image so for this we can
write a simple function I don't want to
get bogged down in what this function
does but basically what we're doing here
is that we're feeding in a model that's
already been trained as one of the
arguments we're feeding in the image
that we'd like to produce predictions on
from from that model and then we're
storing the probabilities here by
calling the predict method from the
model that we've trained and then we're
basically showing the image and then
showing the classes that we want to
predict so let's look at the first image
that we looked at right that we kind of
thought was maybe a frog sort of kind of
it we actually see that the model kind
of sort of maybe thinks that's a frog as
well is it can it's obvious that the
model is pretty confused about this
right so here you can see right this is
our individual image here this is a
little bit difficult to see but across
the bottom here we basically have our
classes and we can see here is the Frog
class and the model doesn't quite
understand that that that that's the
prediction that we should be making for
for this particular image so in the
debugging process this is sort of
something that you can use to
qualitatively go in and explore some of
the results of this model so this
indicates not just that the model is
wrong but that the model is actually
unsure about which of any of these types
of classes this image fits in right so
that might inform the kind of debugging
that you do later on so going forward
some things that you might want to try
with some of these networks you can
always add more common convolutional
layers that's somewhat restricted by
compute power and resources that you
have these things can quickly take a
long time to train if you build deeper
and deeper networks you can look at
different optimizers or learning
algorithms and tuning learning rates
and you can also use qualitative
debugging tools like the probability
output that we looked at before okay so
we'll quickly go through looking at it
yeah some of it will it won't be done
there there's a built in class that you
can actually use in the carrot API that
would be vegetable notation for you yep
exactly exactly yeah
good question okay so very quickly let's
look at an example of a different
predicted task and here we'll actually
go through some of the data
pre-processing steps so in the previous
task right we sort of had a can data set
which was nice to work with and we
didn't have to do much pre-processing in
this case we're working with text which
typically needs a little bit more
pre-processing to be done before being
fed to an algorithm so in this case
we'll look at a data set of tweets that
contain disaster-related keywords so it
might be tempting to think that if a
tweet comes in and it has a disaster
related keyword that we should say have
some alert about it but since social
media text is often noisy we're not
guaranteed that each tweet that has some
disaster related keyword is actually
about a disaster so in this case what
we'd like to do is we'd like to build a
binary classifier to basically filter
out those tweets that are not relevant
and keep those that are relevant so we
can read in this data and I've included
this github repo with all this stuff
here and this data is included with that
you can read in this data as a data
frame here here we just we're just
looking at the text in one column the
string label in another column so again
relevant means something that we'd like
to keep as a positive example and then
there's another class called not
relevant we can see the distribution of
those two things here so you can see
roughly there's about a 60/40 split
between the different types of classes
here obviously it's not surprising since
that the Twitter data sets that the
majority class is non relevant but just
kind of a good sanity check to see to
see that our class imbalance problems is
in isn't too bad before we feed these
two to a model so before we see the data
- a model
we'll actually need to create numeric
labels so that's basically what we're
doing here we're creating an integer
label where we're mapping relevant to
one and not relevant to zero and then
finally we'll get to some of the the
text processing steps here so normally
what needs to be done in natural image
processing tasks is a lot of text
normalization cleaning things like that
for this case we won't get too too
involved in that but we will look at two
tools that are packaged with carrots
that are pretty nice to use so first off
what we're doing is we're just going to
slice off the text from our data frame
we'll slice off the integer labels that
we've created and now on sanshi ate this
tokenizer class and this takes an
argument for the number of words that
we'd like to to pay attention to and so
this basically produces a frequency
ranking of all the words in your
vocabulary of your training set and
we'll just take the top 10,000 in this
case we'll fit the tokenizer class on
the text that we've constructed and then
to actually feed into the network will
need to create sequences and instead of
having sequences of strings that get fed
to the network what we'll do is we'll
use this text to sequences method to
actually map each of those words to an
integer and you can just think of that
integer as an ID for that word so now
what we're looking at is a list of
integers each integer mapping an ID to a
word and then we'll pad those with a set
of zeroes at the beginning of each of
these fees lists so you can see that our
output shape for our input data becomes
this matrix of 10,000 instances by 32
columns and the first element in our
data again it's just a series of
different integers padded by zeros at
the beginning so what we've done here is
we transform each document into a
sequence of integers again each integer
can be just thought of as a word ID and
since not all of our documents are
guaranteed to be the same length what we
do is we find the maximum length of the
document their length of the maximum
a training set and then pad each
additional pad each document that's
shorter with zeros okay so those are the
pre-processing steps this is a fairly
similar outline for for building the
model the difference' to being that
we're importing some different classes
one being the embedding class which
basically just learns a representation
for these words through the model
training process and then obviously
since we're building a different type of
network we're going to import the LS TM
class it's all we're doing here is again
following our same recipe of
instantiating an empty model container
adding an embedding layer adding a
recurrent layer with 64 units and then
finally adding a dense layer at the end
to make a single prediction in this case
right since we have a binary
classification problem we're just going
to predict either 1 or 0 at the end ok
and then fit as before the only
difference here right we're calling a
specific batch size for this argument
here so a batch size is just indicating
how many samples in each update for the
network the the model should see there's
very there's various other arguments
that could be taken in the fit method as
well
ok so additional things that you could
try with building a document
classification network we talked a lot
about lsdm networks there's other
recurrent layers that you could try that
come as classes in the Charis library
grooves are gated recurrent units you
could also try normal recurrent layers
as well and then there are interesting
things even before we start building the
network right about text processing so
in this case we have tweets which
contain things like hashtags so there's
a sort of a design question there about
should we process those the way we do
any other token should we remove those
entirely and then another thing to
experiment with would be using things
like pre-trained embeddings in our
embedding layer ok so we're running a
little bit short on time so let's go
into the final final stage of the
presentation here looking at some of the
feature extraction layers or some of the
output of those layers to understand
what's going on in our network so
often we'll see a particularly can bring
off of the shelf and we'll try to sort
of fit that example to our particular
machine learning problem but in some
cases we'll need to tweak things or
modify the network in some way in order
to make it fit our problem best so in
this case let's look at adding a
recurrent layer to RLS TM from our
example above so in this case we're just
building a function here that will
return model architecture is that the
same as our our last LS TM network the
only difference here is that we're
adding a couple layers here so after the
first recurrent layer we're adding
another recurrent layer with 64 more
units and then connecting that to
another dense layer before outputting a
prediction right so the thought here
being that maybe we don't have a
powerful enough model for for our
prediction tasks and so we can add more
layers to add capacity to the model what
you'll see if you do that is go get this
nice error here and so you'll see
basically at the bottom there's this
dimension mismatch where your are our
second lsdm layer is expecting a
dimensionality of three but we're only
passing a dimensionality of T so you
might think what the heck how do we get
around that one tactic that you can
employ is to basically build sort of
partial networks so instead of building
the network all the way down to your
prediction layers you can basically
build the network all the way up to the
layer before the one that's throwing an
error and then feed data through that to
see what the output is so in this case
we're just building sort of a partial
Network where we're only including an
embedding layer and an LS TM layer and
then we'll just feed some fake data
through that to see what the output is
to sort of understand and diagnose the
problem from there so here we're calling
that function above to build our partial
network that we're going to use to
predict on data we're producing some
fake data which is just going to be a
hundred rows by a hundred columns and
then we can compile that model and
predict on that fake data so we're not
training the model we don't actually
want to use this for prediction or
anything we just want to see what data
looks like when we feed it through it
and so in this case we can see that
indeed the problem is that
we've only got two dimensions in our
lair
or in our output data there so there's
actually an easy fix for this one thing
that you can do is that each of these
LST M layers has an argument forward
returning sequences and if you flip that
to true and we feed data through our
network again now we see that we have a
three dimensional output which is what's
required for our network and so in this
case we're outputting actually a
sequence of the data points that come
from that
LST M layer and then feeding it to a
second recurrent layer that can then
kind of cascades through the rest of the
network okay and this is just an example
that if you Disick's the problem so this
is a common issue that it's experienced
in building these these networks often
is a mismatch between the dimensionality
of your data and this is just sort of a
principled way to kind of go through
look at what's happening in data flow
through the network and then debug so
finally we will look at actually
visualizing a layer in one of our
networks so look at what I'm kind of
calling task-specific word embeddings so
often people have probably seen plots of
worded betting's that are learned in an
unsupervised way that sort of captures
semantic relationships between words but
we've also seen that word embeddings can
be used as an input layer in our model
and the weights of that layer can be
tuned for a predictive task so we can
actually pop those weights out and
visualize what they look like for a
predictive task so in this case I've
trained a trained offline in LST M for
part of speech tagging and so we're
popping out the layers of that embedding
layer and seeing what kind of
representations that's learned in this
case so the first thing you'll notice is
that we have some pretty tightly
connected clusters of words and so we
can actually zoom in and see what some
of those words are and see what the what
the representations are that our network
is learning in this case so if you look
at this cluster here actually see that
the network in its learning task right
which is sort of like a grammatically
centered task is learning a cluster of
of words in this case
if we look out to some other clusters as
well we can actually see that it's also
learning some more grammatically nuanced
things right so in this cluster you can
see that it's actually learning plural
nouns so things like minds passions
postcards etc we can actually see that
it's actually learning different tenses
of verbs as well so here we have past
participle verbs down here so things
like tract improve singled question
things like that so this is just to show
that it's a nice kind of debugging tool
to see that to basically provide a
sanity check to see that our network is
learning the things that we think it's
learning okay so I will wrap up there so
we've done is we've gone through some
popular architectures we've kind of gone
through a very very quick and dirty
overview of deep learning in general and
some popular architectures that you can
implement with this tool we've learned
about carrots as a tool to implement the
use and sort of to pick apart models to
understand what's happening a little bit
under the hood
and looked at ways to kind of peer into
the network for debugging and also for
visualization at a higher level I hope
I've taken at least a little bit of the
mystery out of neural networks it's
really easy to treat these things as
black boxes but hopefully this gets you
started on some examples that you can
implement yourself pick apart break
figure out how to fix them and kind of
go from there
with that I'll conclude so thanks
[Applause]